Hello, welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
My name is Angela Lom Mckang. I hope
you're having a wonderful blessed day.
We are going to be digging into the word
of God to find answers. Maybe you have
questions. Well, I know I've had
questions and so we are going to just
This is where we find our answers. Okay.
And thank you for joining us. Thank you
for your prayers and support of this
worldwide ministry. It is very much
appreciated.
Well, I am going to introduce the my
wonderful panel. And the panel that we
have today are three Bible characters.
Yes, three of them. We have a a a J DJ,
a John, a Daniel, and a John. And so I'm
going to start first with Pastor James
Rapidity. Did I say John? No, James.
James and John. We're going to start
with Pastor James Raffid. Welcome,
Pastor James.
>> So good to be here, Angie. Looking
forward to the questions and the
opportunity to find some answers in the
word of God.
>> Amen. Always. That's where we get th our
answers right here. Uh, Pastor Daniel
Maronei, welcome.
>> Thank you so much. I always appreciate
the Bible Q&A and thank you all for
sending your questions in. They were
really great this time. Thank you.
>> All right. And right next to me is the
love of my life, Pastor John Lang.
Welcome. Hi.
>> Always good to be on the program with
you, honey. And thank you for the
challenging questions.
>> Oh yes.
>> That always causes us to dig deeper and
find the answers in God's word. It's
always a blessing.
>> Always a blessing. Maybe you've just
tuned in and you want to send your
questions in. Well, you can text your
questions into us at 6182283975.
Or you can email your question by going
to bibleqa3abn.tv.
Maybe you're an Instagram person. 3ABN
official. And before we go into our
questions, we're going to ask Pastor
James Raffid to open with prayer.
Father in heaven, just want to thank you
again for this opportunity that we have
to open your word and to seek for
answers. Thank you for all the good
questions that have come in. Please send
your Holy Spirit to be with us and to be
with each viewer and give us answers
that are practical and significant for
our our needs and where we are in our
walk with you. We pray in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, we're going to open
the word of God together. Whether you're
a lifelong believer or you're just
curious about what the Bible has to say,
let's go on a journey, an excursion
through the word of God. Well, here's
our first question for Pastor James.
Was Jacob guilty of cavitiousness in
Genesis 25 verse 29-34?
If so, why does the Bible remain silent
about it while only pointing to Esau's
nonchalants
about the birthright? Jacob was clearly
profiting from his covetousness.
Let's go.
>> Great question. Thank you for that
question. Let's just look at the verses.
Verses 29 to 34 and the nonchalant
attitude of Esau. Jacob saw pottage and
Esau came in from the field. It says,
"And he was faint. And Esau said to
Jacob, feed me, I pray thee, with some
of that red pottage, for I am faint.
Therefore, his name is called Edom,
which means red." And Jacob said, "Sell
me this day thy birthright." That's the
coveting team. And Esau said, "Behold,
I'm at a point to die. What profit shall
this birthright do to me?" And Jacob
said, "Swear to me this day." And he
swear unto him. And he sold his
birthright unto Jacob. Then Jacob gave
Esau bread and pottage of lentils, and
he did eat and drink and rose up and
went his way. Thus, now notice this
phrase, Esau despised his birthright.
Now, we know that Jacob was guilty of
covetousness, right? And Jacob's
covetousness led him to deceive his
father later, his father Isaac, and to
draw his brother Esau's hatred. And it
also separated him from his mother
Rebecca until her death. It also led
Jacob to be deceived by his uncle Laban,
just as he he had been deceived. You
know, the Bible says in Galatians 6:7,
"Be not deceived. God is not mocked.
Whatsoever a man sws, that shall he also
reap."
So this entire story of Jacob's
covetousness and where it led to is in
the Bible. You know, the Bible's not
silent about it. Rather, it explains it
in detail. That's why we know he was
covetous. And it shows us where covetous
leads to and how it can ruin
relationships, how it can break up
homes, how it can separate families and
loved ones forever. Jacob never saw his
mother again. Now, the reason why Esau's
nonchalant attitude or lack of respect
for his birthright is pointed out so
much and and made much worse than
Jacob's covetousness and deception is
because Esau disregarded his birthight
and that showed a lack of interest in
heavenly things. you know, God uh Jesus
Christ, the plan of salvation which has
cost so much the eternal paternal
relentless changeless matchless love of
our heavenly father that's manifest in
his only begotten son meant nothing to
Esau next to his own selfish desires for
the hunt to satisfy his appetite and to
live as he pleased. The Bible says in
Romans 9:13, "As it is written, Jacob
have I loved, but Esau have I hated."
Now God loved Jacob the deceiver and God
loves every person, all sinners. And
because God loved Jacob, he was not
willing to remain a deceiver. It was the
love of God, the goodness of God that
led Jacob to repentance.
Jacob humbled himself. You know, in the
dark despair of his sin, Jacob wrestled
with God. And wrestling through the
darkness, weakened by the angel's hand,
Jacob refused to let go of that angel
until he had gained the blessing of God.
And we read about that in Genesis
32 beginning with verse 27. It says,
"And he said unto him," that is the
angel said to Jacob, "What is thy name?"
And he said, "Jacob," which actually
means deceiver. "And he said, thy name
shall be called no more Jacob, but
Israel, for as a prince hast thou power
with God and with men, and hast
prevailed."
So the issue with Jacob is not lightly
looked over in the Bible. Jacob had a
major problem and Esau had a major
problem. The response of Jacob
differentiates him from Esau. Jacob's
sin was exposed. Its result reaped. Its
consequence was felt. Its ultimate
punishment was forgiven. Why? Because
Jacob, unlike Esau,
accepted the grace of God and allowed it
to transform him. You know, all those
who develop a character that loves the
world and self-will are reflected in
Esau. That's why God says, "I hate
that." It's not that he hates Esau. He
hates that character that is reflected
by Esau. Turning away from what heaven
offers for the things of this world.
Jacob prized heaven and his heavenly
father above everything this world had
to offer. And by the grace of God, may
we do the same.
>> Right. Jacob wrestled with the angel.
Who was that angel? Wasn't it God?
Jesus.
>> Yes. It was Christ.
>> Yeah. Beautiful. Thank you for that.
Okay, Pastor Moronei.
In Genesis 1, God created people, male
and female. But then later in Genesis 2,
the word goes into detail about how God
breathed life into man.
Does this mean that people were on earth
before Adam and Eve were formed? This is
from Tracy in Tennessee.
Tracy, hey, thank you so much for that
question. And it could seem like that
was the case what you just said there,
but I like what you said as far as
chapter one being the overall statement
and then chapter 2 being the detail of
how it all happened.
Um, let me read it for our viewers here
in Genesis chapter 1 26 and 27. And God
said, "Let us make man in our image,
after our likeness, and let them have
dominion over the fish of the sea, and
over the fowl of the air, and over the
cattle, and over all the earth, and over
every creeping thing that creepeth upon
the earth."
>> So God created man in his own image,
and male and female created he them.
Then in chapter 2 verse 7, it talks
about God breathing into Adam's nostrils
the breath of life and then man becoming
a living soul. Then he had him name all
the animals.
And while he was doing that, he said,
"How come I don't have a mate?" That's
what Adam said. Now that's the Moricone
translation.
Adam gets anesthesia and he wakes up in
the posttop and uh he sees bone of his
bone and flesh of his flesh next to him
Eve.
Then it says therefore shall a man leave
his father and his mother and shall
cleave unto his wife and they shall be
one flesh. You know when you or I write
or talk a lot of times we will say
something general statement and then we
go back and then we give in the details
maybe something that somebody's
interested in or we ourselves so that
people can follow the story or the logic
there. We read in Matthew chapter 19
where Jesus is talking to the Pharisees.
He's talking to them about divorce. They
were asking him trying to trick him. But
he answered and said unto them, "Have
you not read that he which made them at
the beginning, this is the chapter one
part, made them at the beginning, made
them male and female, and said, for this
cause shall a man leave his father and
his mother, and shall cleave to his
wife, and they twain shall be one
flesh." So you can see where he actually
joins chapter 1 and chapter 2 there. And
by the way, there wasn't any chapters,
right, when Moses wrote Genesis.
And then in Genesis chapter 3 and verse
20, uh it says that Adam called his
wife's name Eve
because she was the mother of all
living. So everybody came through Eve is
what that's saying. So she was the
original mother.
By the way, this goes along with
science.
Not sure if you've heard of
mitochondrial DNA, but um
when the uh sperm gets into the egg, the
egg actually destroys the mitochondria
in the sperm so that it won't affect the
uh viability of the egg. And so all you
have left, and by the way, there's two
DNA. There's a nucleus of a cell that
has the DNA in it. And then
mitochondria, those are the little
factories in every cell, maybe four to
600 mitochondria that crank out energy
to so that the cell can live and
survive. And so
that's why the mitochondrial DNA is just
from the female. And so there's actually
something called the mitochondrial Eve.
In other words, science realizes that
every every person goes back to one
female. And so that goes along also with
this um thought that um you know there
weren't anybody there wasn't anybody
created before Adam and Eve. They were
the original parents and we've all
descended from them. So thank you again
Tracy for that question.
>> Amen. From one blood came all nations.
Right.
>> That's right.
>> That's where we all came from. Adam and
Eve, that's our parents. We are all
brothers and sisters on this earth.
Praise God. All right, Pastor Lom
>> Mckang.
>> Is the Sabbath here on earth a type that
points to the great Sabbath? Which means
the books are reviewed after the
thousand years have ended, not during
the thousand years. This is from Monica.
An email sent in.
>> Thank you, Monica, for that question.
Now, there is to answer this question
something called application and
prophetic fulfillment. Now there are
some similarities we find in scripture
between the sabbatical rest that took
place in the seventh year that can be
related to what happens during the
millennium. Let me give you some
examples. Let me talk about the
sabetical rest year which was a law of
agriculture among the Jews. I read in
Leviticus chapter 25
>> verses 1-4.
And the Lord spoke to Moses on Mount Si,
saying, "Speak to the children of Israel
and say to them,
when you come into the land which I give
you, then the land shall keep a Sabbath
to the Lord. Six years you shall sew
your field, and six years you shall
prune your vineyard and gather its
fruit. But in the seventh year there
shall be a Sabbath of solemn rest for
the land, a Sabbath to the Lord." And
something else happened in that seventh
year. Leviticus chapter 27:4.
And this talks about it. Now, this is
coming down to the 70th. In the year of
Jubilee, the field shall return to him
from whom it was bought
>> to the one who owned the land as a
possession. Now, let's put that let's
put that together in the context of
6,000 years of sin
>> and the millennium. At the end of the at
the end of sin, the land is going to
return to its rightful owner. Who's the
rightful owner? God is the rightful
owner. But there is a year, there's a
thousand years of rest, which is a
millennium.
>> No one is alive on earth except Satan
and his evil angels. There's no sewing.
There's no reaping. The saints are in
heaven. And at the end of that thousand
years, there is the judgment of the
wicked that the Bible talks about. And
Paul in the book of 1 Corinthians
chapter 6:2 talks about that. So when
we're in heaven for a thousand years,
the question you asked was uh will the
judgment be at the end of the thousand
years or during the thousand years? The
judgment will be that is reviewing the
records will be during the thousand
years. 1 Corinthians 6 and verse 2 to4
do you not know that the saints will
judge the world? And if the world will
be judged by you, are you unworthy to
judge the smallest matters? Verse three,
do you not know that we shall judge
angels? That's the angels that sinned,
how much more things that pertain to
this life. So the angels that sinned and
sinners in general will be judged during
the thousand years. That is the only way
that you go from investigation to
verdict to the sentencing. And the
sentent the sentencing happens at the
end of the thousand years. Revelation 20
7-9. Now when the thousand years have
expired, Satan will be released from his
prison and will go to deceive the
nations which are in the four corners of
the earth. And what's going to happen?
Verse 9, they went upon the breath of
the earth and surrounded the camp of the
saints and the beloved city and fire
came down from God out of heaven and
devoured them. That happens at the end
of the thousand years.
>> Wow.
>> That's a whole lot for three minutes.
>> Good job.
>> Woo. That was a lot. But three minutes
is right. Yeah. But there is a judgment,
isn't there? That's right.
>> Yeah, there is a judgment coming.
>> Thank you, honey. All right, Pastor
Raffidy, could you explain how the
Sabbath is calculated? See, we're going
from one Sabbath to another question.
Can you explain Could you explain how
the Sabbath is calculated? I am seeking
to understand the biblical and
historical basis for why Saturday is
recognized as the seventh day of the
week. This is from Enoch in Rwanda.
>> Thank you for your question, Enoch.
Let's begin with the biblical. The
evidence starts in Genesis 2:es 1-3
where God rests on the seventh day from
all his creation work. The week of
creation uh found not in the moon or in
the stars but in the Bible ends with the
Sabbath. So it begins biblically. It
begins with creation week. The seventh
day being the Sabbath. That is
reiterated in Exodus 20:es 8-1 11 where
God calls his people to remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy because in
six days God created the heavens and the
earth and on the seventh day he rested.
So then he reiterates that the Sabbath
is a memorial of creation and the
Sabbath is the Sabbath of the the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
our God. So it is the Lord's day unlike
some people who think that Sunday is the
Lord's day. It's actually the seventh
day Sabbath or Saturday that's the
Lord's day. But I think the greatest
evidence historically and biblically for
the Sabbath is found in Luke 23. And
we're going to begin reading in Luke
chapter 23 and verse 50. It says here,
"And behold, there was a man named
Joseph, a counselor, and he was a good
man and a just." And it says in verse
40, 51, "The same had not consented to
the counsel and the deed of them who
crucified Christ. He was of Arythea,
city of the Jews, who also himself
waited for the kingdom of God. V vers V
vers V vers V vers V vers V vers V vers
V vers V vers V verse 52. The man went
unto Pilate and begged the body of
Jesus. Verse 53. And he took it down and
wrapped it in linen, laid it in a
suppler that was heuned in stone wherein
never a man was laid. And that was the
preparation day. That was Friday or as
some Christians call it Good Friday, the
day that Jesus died. So there's the
historical reference for Christ died on
Good Friday or Friday. And that was the
preparation day. And the Sabbath drew
on. So the Sabbath is Saturday. And the
women also, verse 55, which came from
Galilee, followed after and beheld the
supplr, and how the body was laid. Verse
56. And they returned and prepared
spices, and ointments, and rested the
Sabbath day according to the
commandment. There's your reference to
Exodus into Genesis. And then in verse
one of chapter 24, now on the first day
of the week, very early in the morning
that Sunday, they came into the supplr
bringing the spices they had prepared
and certain others with them, and they
found the stone rolled away from the
suppler, and they entered in and found
not the body of the Lord Jesus. He
resurrected on Sunday. So there's your
biblical evidence and your historic
evidence.
>> Amen. I like that. Biblical and
historical. Yes. And the word of God is
the one we trust, but it corresponds
with history, too. Amen. and thank you
for that. Okay, Pastor Mooney,
how does the red heer in Numbers chapter
19 relate to the endtime events?
I would like to explain to a church
member how this relates to Jesus's
second coming. I don't believe it
relates, but she says it does. This is
from Tammy in Kansas.
>> Well, Tammy, thank you for that
question. It actually gave me the
opportunity to challenge here because I
didn't know either. So, I'm This is what
I discovered here.
>> Amen.
>> Um,
here's what I found. The red heer
significance, particularly the search
for a perfect red cow, unblenmished.
>> It's tied to biblical prophecy about
rebuilding the third temple in Jerusalem
and heralding the second coming of the
Messiah with its ashes needed for
purification rights. While some Jewish
groups await the 10th red hepher as a
sign of the Messiah's arrival, many
Christians view the red heer as symbolic
of Jesus's ultimate sacrifice,
fulfilling the ancient purification laws
and believe his return precedes the
literal temple building with different
interpretations of the timeline and the
events. So recent births of red heers in
Israel have intensified speculation
about these endtime events.
>> So the context as far as historical
uh only there's only been nine red heers
that were sacrificed according to the
Mishna
>> with the 10th red heer believed to be
sacrificed by the Messiah.
>> So they're waiting for the Messiah to
come and sacrifice this 10th red heer. M
>> and then the modern resurgence of this
prophecy, the idea gained significant
momentum after the 1967
6 day war which brought the temple mount
>> back into Israeli control. And then this
third temple connection, there's
organizations called the temple
institute that believe the ashes are
essential to purifying the site and the
priests for the third temple.
So, Christians, end times, some
evangelical groups believe that the
third temple's construction is a
prerequisite for the Antichrist, the
tribulation, and the eventual return of
Jesus.
Well, Tammy, all that being said,
I when I read chapter uh 19 of Numbers,
all I get out of it is the detailed
rules or directions given to Moses and
Aaron regarding purification rights.
They were to use the ashes of a red
hepher as part of the ceremony required
to become ceremonially pure
after touching a dead body or other
sins. Here's what verses 17 and 18 say.
And for an unclean person, they shall
take of the ashes of the burnt hepher of
purification for sin and running water
and shall put them into a vessel. So
like, you know, they got these ashes
slurring around in this running water.
And then a clean person shall take a
hissup and then dip it into this water
and then sprinkle it upon the tent like
somebody died in the tent. Well, then
that was an unclean tent. So they would
sprinkle this water on there and all the
vessels they would sprinkle it and then
upon the persons that were there and
upon him that touched a bone or one
slain or one dead or a grave. So again,
that's what I get out of it. the actual
Bible. I don't The rest of it came from
what was just shared here, other ideas,
but bars prophecy.
>> All right. Okay.
>> Interesting. And somebody may ask, what
is a hea? It's a reddish brown cow.
Somebody may not know, right? That's
right. So, yeah, it's a reddish brown
cow. Big old thing.
>> Okay, let's go to the next question. All
right, Pastor John.
How was Jesus three days and nights in
the heart of the earth when he died on
Friday and raised on Sunday? This is
from Pastor Johnson, not Ryan. The
viewer says that. Okay. I just want to
make that clear.
>> Okay. Well, there's something in the
Bible called inclusive reckoning, which
simply means any part of the day counts
as the whole day. Now, one of the
challenges that people have had is we
try to put mechanical time into biblical
time.
>> You know, and people say, well, if Jesus
was in the earth three days and three
nights, it had to be a full 72 hours.
Now, the problem with that thinking is
if he had to be in the earth 72 hours,
one second beyond that would mean he
rose on the fourth day.
>> And they don't think about that. So,
consider the following. The days are
counted sunset to sunset, not midnight
to midnight like today.
>> That's true.
>> And um meaning we count differently than
the Bible today, right?
>> The starting day is counted as day one
>> even if only a part of it has passed.
Methods used throughout the Old
Testament will show you how inclusive
reckoning uh fits. For example, when
Esther was in crisis and she had to go
be before the king, she was nervous and
she said in Esther 4:16, "Fast for me 3
days, night or day."
>> But notice verse chapter 5 verse one,
"On the third day Esther put on her
royal robes." Now notice she did that on
the third day,
>> but she told them to fast for her three
days. She didn't say 72 72 hours. So any
part of the day once again is considered
the entire day.
>> You go further for Jesus and uh the
second one Jesus own prophecy sets the
framework in Matthew 12:40. Jesus said
the son of man will be three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth.
Elsewhere he said in Matthew 16:21 on
the third day I will rise. Yeah. But in
Mark 8:3031 he said after three days.
Once again, you notice are that's is
that a conflict? No,
>> it's not a contradiction. It is
equivalent expressions under something
called inclusive reckoning. Anyway,
anyway, I'm getting upon the third day.
Let me give you some examples.
>> Day one, Friday, as Pastor James pointed
out, the preparation day,
>> right?
>> Jesus is crucified and dies before
sunset, right?
>> Buried quickly before the Sabbath
begins, counts as day one. that includes
nightfall. Day two, the Sabbath is Jesus
remains in the tomb all day.
>> He is this is a high Sabbath or also a
Passover Sabbath that now synchronizes
with the weekly Sabbath. That counts as
day two. Full night, full day. Day
three, early Sunday morning. Before
dawn, Jesus rose. The tomb is already
empty when discovered. That counts as
day three. Now, notice this.
Resurrection happens on day three
exactly as foretold. Friday partial of
the day, day and night because inclusive
reckoning once again includes the entire
day. Saturday full day, day and night
two. Sunday partial day and night three.
Now what comes first? I'm going really
mess your mind up.
>> When when the sun sets tonight,
>> whatever day you're on, that's that
night. For example, if it's Tuesday and
the sun sets, that's Wednesday night,
then Wednesday. When the sun sets on
Wednesday, it's Thursday night, then
Thursday. The night always comes first.
No deception, no Roman clock, no need
for Wednesday crucifixion. So, in short,
let's see how the Bible fulfills this.
Matthew 16:21,
>> Jesus said, "I'll be raised the third
day." Matthew 17:23, "And the third day
he will be raised up." Matthew 20:1 19,
"And the third day he will rise up." And
even the Pharisees to Pilate, the
political leader, they said to him,
"Sir,
we remember when he was still alive, how
that deceiver said, "After 3 days, I
will rise." But notice how long they
secured the tomb. In verse 64 of Matthew
27, therefore command that the tomb be
made secure until the third day, not
after the third day, meaning all the
time was fulfilled. That's inclusive
reckoning,
>> wasn't it?
>> Wow,
>> that's a whole lot.
>> That was a lot. I remember years ago um
you did a research on that.
>> Yeah. Back in 1987 88
>> 80s. Yeah. Someone had a question. Well,
maybe you've just tuned in and you said,
"Oh, I have a Bible question. I'd like
to send my question in." Well, you can
text us at 6182283975
or you can email us at Bible
Bible QA at 3ABN.tv
or you can Instagram us 3abn_official.
Send your questions in. We'd love to
answer them. All right, let's keep this
moving. Pastor James,
this is an interesting question. If the
dead know nothing and are waiting for
the second coming of Jesus and there's
no one in heaven or hell, can you please
explain the parable of Luke chapter 16
verse 19-31.
This is from Michael.
>> Wow,
thank you Michael for that question. You
know Luke chapter 16 and the rich man
parable of the rich man and Lazarus has
tripped up a lot of people. Let's just
read it here. Verse 19. And there was a
certain rich man which was clothed in
purple and linen and fared sumptiously
every day. And there was a certain
beggar named Lazarus which was laid at
the gate full of sores. Verse 21. And
desiring to be fed with the crumbs which
fell from the rich man's table.
Moreover, the dogs came and licked his
sores. And it came to pass that the
beggar died and was carried by angels
into Abraham's bosom. And the rich man
also died and was buried. and in hell
lifted up his eyes, being in torments,
and seeth Abraham far off, and Lazarus
in his bosom. And he cried and said,
"Father Abraham, have mercy on me, and
send Lazarus that he may dip the tip of
his finger in water, and cool my tongue
tongue, for I am tormented in this
flame." But Abraham said, "Son, remember
that thou in thy lifetime received thy
good things, and likewise Lazarus evil
things. But now he is comforted, and
thou art tormented." And besides all
this, between us you between you there
is a great between us and you there is a
great gulf fixed so that they which
would pass from fence to you cannot
neither can they pass to us that they
would come from fence.
Then he said, I pray thee therefore,
verse 27, Father, that thou wouldest
send him to my father's house, for I
have five brethren, that they may
testify, that he may testify unto them,
lest they also come into this place of
torment. Abraham saith unto him, they
have Moses and the prophets, let them
hear them." And he said, "Nay, Father
Abraham, but if one went unto them from
the dead, they will repent." And he said
unto them, "If they hear not Moses and
the prophets, neither will they be
persuaded, the one rose from the dead."
It's a parable. You read the story and
you realize right away this can't be
literal because it doesn't make sense.
Parables are symbolic just like prophecy
is symbolic. You can't take it
literally. In verse 30 22, for example,
do saved people go to Abraham's bosom
when they die? No. When we're
resurrected, we go to heaven, not to
someone's bosom. Uh verse 23, do
people's body parts go to hell when they
die? No. When you go to a funeral, if
it's an open casket, the body is right
there. There's no finger missing.
There's no tongue missing. Verse 24, do
people's body parts go to heaven when
they die? No. Verse 25, is there
communion communication between people
in heaven and people in hell? No. So the
parable is given to to teach lessons. We
need to ask ourselves what are the
lessons that are being communicated in
the symbolism of this parable. And by
the way, the word Lazarus, if you look
it up in the Strongs, and you'll learn
how to do that if you come to our 3B and
SAD school of disciplehip and learn how
to use a Strongs looking up Greek and
Hebrew. The word Lazarus has two
meanings. One is a real character. It
was a friend of Jesus that he
resurrected from the grave. And the
other one is a fictitious character. So
right there we know this is a fictitious
story and Jesus has turned it upside
down because normally the story was
understood to me to be taught that the
rich man went to heaven and the poor man
went to hell. But God is trying to tell
us here lesson number one riches gained
are not a sign of God's favor. Number
two, poverty is not a sign of God's
disfavor. Number three, there are no
second chances after death. Hebrews
chapter 9:27 says it is appointed unto
men once to die and after that the
judgment. Three,
four, if we neglect the plain teachings
of God's words, we cannot expect that
mighty miracles will convince us. That's
verse 31. And then uh five, there is a
literal fire that will torment and
consume to ashes those who choose to
reject the gift of salvation. We're not
arguing against hell here. We're arguing
against the nature of hell. What is hell
actually like according to the Bible?
And then finally, there is a literal
heaven where those who accept the gift
of salvation will live for all eternity.
And I pray that each one of us will
choose to be there.
>> That's right. Heaven and hell is very
real, isn't it?
>> Yeah. It's a real place. Wonderful.
Thank you.
>> But you're not going to burn eternally.
That's the part I like. Yeah. Thank you
for that. All right, Pastor Maronei.
This is a question is a little lengthy.
So you listen up.
An employer wrongfully terminated me and
stole legal payments from me.
>> I went through unemployment to receive
benefits after being wrongfully fired.
And I have a case against the boss. I am
struggling with it though because the
Bible says to turn the other cheek,
don't sue, etc.
>> Are we supposed to just get cheated and
just walk away knowing that God will
take care of this in the end? This is
from Rich in New Jersey. Interesting,
>> Rich. Well, my heart goes out to you,
brother, for what's happened to you
there. Mhm.
>> You know, the Bible doesn't explicitly
forbid lawsuits, but it does strongly
encourage settling disputes privately
and then warns against suing fellow
Christians.
>> It also emphasizes defending the poor
and needy. Like Exodus 23:6 says, "Let
no wrong decisions be given in the poor
man's cause."
>> Then Proverbs 3:19, "Open thy mouth,
judge righteously, and plead the cause
of the poor and needy." Mhm. Now, I'm
not sure if your boss was a Christian,
but Matthew 18 provides a framework for
resolving conflicts privately among
believers. You might recall how it says,
"If thy brother shall trespass against
thee, go and tell him his fault between
thee and him alone." And you've probably
done that already. It says, "If he shall
hear thee, thou hast gained thy brother.
And if he doesn't listen, take one or
two more believers. Then if he still
doesn't listen, take it before the whole
church.
>> So this verse in Matthew 5:39-41 is in
the scriptures, you're probably more
than likely referring to this where it
says, "If someone slaps you on your
right cheek, turn to him the other, and
if any man will sue at the law and take
away thy coat, let him have thy cloak
also."
Now these scriptures all have to do with
to me retaliation, you know, revenge.
And I believe Jesus or the Bible is
actually wanting us not to hold any
revengeful or retaliatory spirit.
>> Amen.
>> You know, I've seen it actually eat
people up. When we lived in West
Virginia, I recall a man suing a coal
company because he got black loan.
>> And it took quite a few years. And his
constant thought of of revenge seemed to
eat him up.
I recall when they won the case, he
purchased a travel trailer with the
money and then he passed away not too
long after that.
>> So I remember feeling sorry for him that
the last part of his life, you know,
just was consumed with that idea to get
even. Um, and his focus was all about
getting what he deserved. So he didn't
his life he didn't live a joyful or have
a joyful spirit. And I would say that
the Bible wants you to consider
carefully whether to sue or not and to
trust God that he'll be there to take
care of you. And having that peace that
passes all understanding is worth a lot.
>> Yes.
>> So may the Lord lead you, Rich. In fact,
let me just say a prayer for you right
now, Rich. Father in heaven. Lord, I
thank you for Rich here and so sorry for
what he's going through. M
>> Lord, we pray that your Holy Spirit
would be with him, bringing him your
comfort and providing for him. And
Father, if it's your will, help him to
find even a better job. Lord,
>> thank you for your presence with Rich in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> And thank you, Rich. Blessing.
>> Yeah, it's a difficult one. We know in
Romans 12:19 says, "Vengeance is mine.
He will take care of it, but there is a
time and a place for everything." So,
yes, we understand that.
>> All right, Pastor John. Mhm. This is a
little lengthy
this question. It says, "I know there
are two resurrections and the Bible
states all eyes will see him. If the
dead are in the graves are not resurrect
are not resurrected till the second
resurrection, how do they see him?
>> I know the ones who are alive will be
killed by the brightness of his coming.
Are the ones in the grave resurrected
just to see him? This is from Gianne in
Florida.
>> Well, Gianne, the Bible says there's
going to be a time when everyone that
has ever lived is going to be alive. And
that's at the end of the thousand years.
>> Yes.
>> Where the Bible says uh every knee shall
bow and every tongue shall confess that
Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory of the
father.
>> But now let's talk about these
resurrections. There are two
resurrections. John 5 28 and 29 says,
"Do not marvel at this, for the hour is
coming in which all who are in the
graves will hear his voice and will come
forth. They that have done good to the
resurrection of life. They that have
done evil to the resurrection of
damnation or condemnation depending on
the translation." So there are two
resurrections, but Revelation 20:6 says,
"Blessed and holy is he who has part in
the first resurrection
over such the second death has no
power." So the first resurrection is the
resurrection of life because the second
death cannot affect that person. Meaning
everybody dies once physically.
>> But that eternal death as pastor James
talked about in the parable of the rich
man Lazarus is that death where we are
permanently separated from God where we
will we be consumed. There's no coming
back. And that is the punitive judgment
of the Lord at the end of the thousand
years. But in the first resurrection,
the Lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout and the dead in
Christ will rise first. That's the first
resurrection. So the answer to your
question, are the ones in the graves
resurrected just to see Jesus? Let me
give you a confusing answer, then I'll
answer it.
>> Yes and no. Yes to those who are
righteous. Uh-huh.
>> And um but no to those who are wicked
>> except
>> the statement of Jesus in Matthew chap
26 62-64
because when Jesus was at trial
>> they were persecuting him and listen to
what Jesus said.
>> Yes.
>> And the high priest arose and said to
him Matthew 26:62
do you not answer? Do you answer
nothing?
>> What does these men testif what is it
these men testify against you? But Jesus
kept silent.
>> And the high priest answered and said to
him, "I put you under oath by the living
God." In other words, I adure you are.
>> Tell us if you are the Christ, the son
of God. Here's the key. Verse 64. Jesus
said to him, "It is as you said." Here's
the appointment. Nevertheless, I say to
you,
>> hereafter you will see the Son of Man
sitting at the right hand of power and
coming on the clouds of heaven. So this
group, those that persecuted him,
>> listen to Revelation 1:7.
>> Behold, he is coming with clouds, and
every eye will see him.
>> Yes,
>> even they who pierced him. That was the
appointment Jesus made on the day that
they said, "Are you the Christ?" M
>> he says, "Next time you see me, it's not
going to be a crown of thorns. It's
going to be a crown of glory.
>> And then all the tribes of the earth
will mourn because of him." So those who
persecuted Christ will have a special
resurrection to see the gospel triumph.
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> They're in trouble.
>> They're in trouble. But some will be
alive when Jesus comes, too. Right.
>> That's right. Saints
>> will be caught up also with the dead.
With the dead in Christ. Thank you so
much for that. Let's move on. Okay,
Pastor James, here's your final
question. Can you elaborate on the
meaning of Jeremiah 10 1-4?
Am I unintentionally
worshiping and or inviting the spirits
of pagan deities when I decorate a tree
during Christmas holidays? This is from
Shalomar.
>> Thank you for your question, Shalomar.
And the immediate answer to that is no,
you are not. Jeremiah chapter 10 is not
speaking about Christmas trees. It's
speaking about idols made of wood that
are carved and ordained with silver and
they're worshiped as a god. We can read
this in Jeremiah chapter 10. Let's start
with verse 5 or verse one and through 5.
Hear ye the word which the Lord speaketh
unto you, oh house of Israel. Thus
sayith the Lord. Verse two, learn not
the way of the heathen, and be not
dismayed at the signs of heaven. For the
heathen are dismayed at them. For the
customs of the people are vain. For one
cutth a tree out of the forest, the work
of the hands of the workmen with the
axe. They deck it with silver and gold.
They fasten it with nails and with
hammers that it move not. They are
upright as the palm tree, but speak not.
They must needs be born because they
cannot go. Be not afraid of them for
they cannot do evil, neither also is it
in them to do good. Now, I want to just
take this moment to clarify something
that's really important when you study
the Bible. Use more than one version of
the Bible. There are many versions of
the Bible that can bring lots of clarity
to the text. The King James is difficult
to understand here. So, let me just
share with you the NIV. They cut a tree
out of the forest and a craftsman shapes
it with his chisel. They adorn it with
silver and gold. They fasten it with a
hammer and nail so it will not totter.
Like a scarecrow in a cucumber field,
their idols cannot speak. They must be
carried because they cannot walk. Do not
fear them. They can do no harm, nor can
they do any good. And verse 8 even goes
on to say this in the King James. It
says, "But they are altogether brutish
and foolish, and the stock is the
doctrine of vanities." But notice how
the NAV says it. They are all senseless
and foolish. They are taught by
worthless wooden idols. So, we're
talking here about idols. A tree
decorated for Christmas, lights hung on
the house, fences or bushes outside,
house plants, pictures or plaques hung
with woody sayings, or Thanksgiving
decorations, or balloons and ribbons for
uh birthday parties and other decor. We
don't worship any of that. We use that
to bring warmth, to decorate, to fill
our spaces where we live. And we
especially use it on special occasions.
God is specifically talking about idols
that are shaped out of wood, that are
carved, that are decorated, that are set
up, that people worship. He's comparing
the idol worship of the heathen with
what he called his people not to do, and
that was to not worship any idols. You
can read about this in the second
commandment. Don't make an image or bow
down and worship it. and to be separate
and distinct from the heathen and
worship only one God, the invisible God,
Jehovah.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. Right to the
point. All right, let's move on. Our
final question, Pastor Maronei.
This is a interesting one also. If my
spouse is alive, but we are divorced, am
I calling myself a Christian? Can I
marry again?
Well, that's a it's an anonymous
question. It's not a so I don't know the
>> right
>> details of the situation here. So, I'm
just going to give you a more of a
general answer. Let's say so God was the
author of marriage and he instituted it
in the Garden of Eden. And Eve was
definitely bone of Adam's bone and flesh
of his flesh. Genesis 2:24 says,
"Therefore shall a man leave his father
and his mother and shall cleave unto his
wife, and they shall be one flesh." So
God intended for the union of this holy
pair to endure forever.
And the 7th Adventist Church adheres to
this view of marriage and home without
any reservation
believing that any lowering of this high
view to that extent is lowering the
heavenly ideal. So the 7th Adventist
Church belief allows for remarage after
divorce primarily when adultery occurs.
And this is based on Jesus's teaching in
Matthew 19:9 where he Jesus says, "And I
say unto you, whosoever shall put away
his wife except for fornication and
shall marry another committh adultery,
and who so marrith her which is put away
doth commit adultery."
But the church emphasizes forgiveness,
compassion, and restoration, allowing
for pastoral guidance for all situations
with a focus on repentance and God's
healing grace for those who have fallen
short.
Though policies have evolved to handle
complex cases
with grace, acknowledging that physical
abuse
also warrants protection and safety,
making remarage possible for the wronged
party. Well, I don't know enough about
your situation to give a definitive
answer. Each case is unique.
>> So, let me just stick with the ideal.
Here's God speaking through Paul in 1
Corinthians 7:10 and 11. And unto the
married I command, yet not I, but the
Lord, let not the wife depart from her
husband, but and if she depart, let her
remain unmarried or be reconciled to her
husband, and let not the husband put
away his wife. Again, thank you for that
question. I hope it helps.
>> Thank you for that. I tell you, I'm not
gonna marry again. Are we?
>> Neither am I, honey. One choice. You're
it.
>> We said forever together, eternity and
view. I can't do this again.
>> Thank you for that. All right. This is a
quick to the point question. It's
perfect for you.
>> Can you can you explain the three angels
messages? Some people are saying that
this is not true. This is from Devita in
New York.
>> Thank you, Dvita. Well, in a nutshell, I
know either James or I could have
answered this because we love
Revelation. The answer, the short answer
is the three angels and messages are
very true.
>> Yes.
>> According to Revelation, these are three
warnings that are issued to Christians
and non-Christians alike. Now, God, this
is something beautiful. He's Bible says
Jesus is not willing. God is not willing
that any should perish. Before judgment
comes, there's always a warning. And
these are three warnings issued in
Revelation 14:es 6 to13. But I'll start
with verse uh six here. Then I saw
another angel flying in the midst of
heaven, having the everlasting gospel to
preach to those who dwell on the earth,
to every nation, tribe, tongue, and
people, saying with a loud voice, "Fear
God and give glory to him for the hour
of his judgment has come. And worship
him who made heaven and earth and the
sea and the springs of water." Two
warnings. We are living in the judgment
hour prior to the coming of Christ.
Yeah,
>> everyone's going to be judged either for
eternity, that is to be saved, or
eternally lost. But there's a call back
to fear God and worship him who made
heaven and earth. That's a call back to
the Sabbath. That is the only
commandment in the Bible that surrounds
that surrounds creation. Remember the
Sabbath to keep it holy. Exodus 20:8.
Exodus 20:1 is connected to that
command. For in six days the Lord made
the heaven and earth, the sea, and all
that is in them, and rested the seventh
day. Therefore, the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day and hollowed it. If you are
a Christian, God is calling you back to
true worship, not tradition. Not Sunday,
not the day set up by man or by pagan
systems, but the day that the Lord
blessed at the end of creation week. As
Pastor James said earlier in our
questions, it's a call back to true
worship. What's the second angel?
Revelation 14:8. And another angel
followed, saying, Babylon is fallen, is
fallen, that great city, because she has
made all nations drink of the wine of
the wrath of her fornication. Why
fallen? fallen already fallen in the
eyes of God soon to be fallen in the
eyes of man. You see right now the
gospel is heard everywhere but
Revelation 18:4 says come out of her my
people that you part not partake of her
sins and that you not receive of her
plagues and one day Revelation 18:23
says the lamp of the light shall no
longer be seen in her anymore. The voice
of the bridegroom shall not be heard in
her anymore. That is right now the voice
of God is calling people that are in
Babylon. But the day is coming that that
voice is going to be silenced. And
finally, Revelation 14:9. Then a third
angel followed. I don't have the time to
cover that is warning against worshiping
the beast and his image, receiving the
mark in his right right hand or in his
forehead. And then it says they're going
to receive the mark of the beast, the
number or the name of the beast. A false
system of worship is pulling God's
people in the wrong direction. And then
in verse 12, it describes exactly who
God is calling those who are coming out
of Babylon to stand with. Revelation
14:12, here is the patience of the
saints. Here are they that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. So wherever you are, join those
who will stand with God when he comes.
>> And you have a booklet, Three Angels
Messages booklet.
>> That's right.
>> At 3ABN, you could get the Three Angels
Message booklet. So, we're going to take
a break and we're going to hear a few
thoughts from our panelists. We'll be
right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live. And then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Welcome back. I hope you were blessed. I
always learn something new and I hope
you do too. Well, we have a few closing
thoughts from our panelists. Pastor
James,
just want to go back to that question
about Jacob and Esau. You know, I really
appreciated that question because the
viewer was pointing out that Jacob was a
deceiver. What about his covetousness?
He was no different than Esau. And I
want to say that is so true. All of us
are sinners. We've all fallen short of
the glory of God. No one is better than
anyone else. And while God reveals that
to each one of us, it's up to us to
determine our future. Are we going to
acknowledge that we're sinners and
accept the gift of salvation? Are we
going to repent and be forgiven and have
eternal life, the gift that Christ has
given us? I hope that that's going to be
your choice.
>> Beautiful. Well said, Pastor Maronei.
>> Well, I just want to thank you for your
questions. I mean, so neat to hear all
these different questions, things that I
never even thought about. So it makes me
think and especially like that red heer
when it helped me to research that.
Thanks a lot for your question.
>> Amen, Pastor John.
>> Revelation 18:4, God's people are
everywhere, but the call of the last
days of the three angels is a gathering
message. Come out of her, my people.
Where's God calling you to? Here is the
patience of the saints. Here are they
that keep the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus. If you're hearing
God's voice, the time to come out is
now. Amen. God bless you.
>> Okay. Wow, I was blessed. Thank you for
tuning in. Stay rooted in the word of
God. This is where we find our answers,
not in the world. We find our answers in
the book. This book. We are people of
the book. Until next time, continue to
put your trust in Jesus. He has a future
and a hope for you. Be blessed. God
bless you.
Heat. Heat.